is there is there a line for how much
they can make you do yeah if you're
going to the hospital for some push-ups
you're kind of weak bro
I guarantee you none of us is going to
the hospital I would go to the north for
that many push-ups
[Music]
a Texas or Tejas High School football
coach is on leave after parents said
multiple students were hospitalized from
being forced to do nearly 400 push-ups
in a one hour workout
that's crazy
what do they have to go to go to the
hospital for I saw David Lucas post
about this and I I agree with his
takeover 400 push-ups in 60 minutes
that's like how many push-ups in a
minute that's a lot it's a lot but it's
also like like because that's like you
gotta go
400 divided by it's one of those [__]
Elementary School 6.6 push-ups a minute
dude you could do six push-ups in a
minute I guess so but it's consistently
for 400 yeah but also though a lot of
these for them they went to the hospital
you could do six months push-ups in a
minute for like first like 10 minutes
but so what David Lucas said he goes
David Lucas the comedian or David
Goggins
he goes um football is a gladiator sport
he's like if you want to be a [__] go
be a cheerleader so I I think like it
Chappelle's like actually but even
cheerleading is hard right like every
sport I remember like every sport has a
hell week yeah and in hell week yeah
you're trying to shake off the rust from
the summer or and it's incredibly hard
it's more for this and yeah it's for
this discipline and you were too ashamed
to even report that I go to the hospital
like oh like I'm hurt like that's being
like such a little [__] and it's crazy
there's people that are willingly like
yeah that was very hard for me take me
in to the point where this coach has to
go on a leave like that's crazy but I
mean like
even if you you have to do a thousand
push-ups within an hour or whatever
right you get rap dope you just [__]
do it like I don't I don't understand
like it's supposed to be hard you signed
up for it but that's exactly what
happened so [__] one parent said her son
was later hospitalized with
Rhabdomyolysis which is a muscle
disorder brought on by stress that can
cause kidney damage or failure that's
his thoughts
they didn't ask her why she has bad
genetics so he basically got cut yeah
he's out yeah this [__] came
untrained so it's that or D train this
guy's is this guy's fault is it is there
a line for how much they can make you do
yeah if you're going to the hospital for
some push-ups you're kind of weak bro
I guarantee you none of us is going to
the hospital I would go to the New York
for that many push-ups
like you shouldn't be doing sports is
what I'm saying to me this is the same
[__] if you tried out for the math team
right and then like let's say okay
everyone we got everyone has 100
questions if you got [__] five
questions wrong you're getting cut like
the coach holds a standard you make the
standard you make the team if you don't
make the standard then get the [__] out
okay so do you think that standard is
achievable 400 in an hour that's a lot I
don't think the coach is pulling [__]
out of his ass I think it's probably oh
that's last year like they run the same
program this is what we did last year
and the year before that or it could be
baked in like it's unachievable but they
want to see their mental endurance does
that too so it could be so many
different factors but true and this is
the year that they're mental Honduras
was like really good it was really good
so they tried and they failed to place
devil advocate though we had this one
coach in like water polo in high school
and he was like a good guy but he also
had no idea what the [__] he was doing
okay that's okay yeah he would just make
us do [__] because it was hard and then
as I got older like what like water pose
notoriously for sure for sure but like
it was things where like just to put us
through pain just to put us through pain
but then as you as I got older and I
knew him later in my life because he
would come around the MMA gym and the
boxing gyms and I would know him and I'd
be like this [__] couldn't do 10
push-ups either bro all right so it's
like okay so there's like a sadism
behind it exactly like there's certain
coaches that are like yeah you need to
do [__] because it's hard it's like an
ego trip yeah he made his box like we
were on the JV team he made his box of
seniors
that's wild that's weird because he was
a boxing guy right and I got knocked I
think I got knocked out dude yeah that's
not good yeah I don't think that's
allowed though for sure for sure for
sure but he was like oh yeah I'm a boxer
he would tell us all that [__] and then
like as I got older and as I got into
the sport I was like this [__]
couldn't punch out of a paper bag bro
like he has no business [__] making
15 year olds box each other and this
[__] doesn't even box and we
weren't doing it safely so there is like
there is that flip side where there can
be coaches that have no idea what the
[__] they're doing and they're like just
do it because it's hard right yeah we
always see it in mcdojo where we saw
where we see all these martial artists
that are just challenging their students
but they're just abusing that video yeah
the Judo guy those are wild videos by
the way so crazy another kid had died
from being slammed oh of course so it's
like okay there is that flip side
because he kept getting slammed over and
over and over and he just straight up
died so if someone's getting raped
though that's pretty serious that's
pretty serious I would kind of
scrutinize the the method so like why
like I don't know anything about if it's
K if it's possible or not or if it's
damaging or whatever but it doesn't
sound wild to me to expect a bunch of
push-ups from 400 push-ups is nothing in
the practice that's like you do more in
the military don't you I mean like
um even in [__] Drumline he did more
push-ups because I remember you like
Canon like we would go play right and
then like let's say you play and then
like there's always this thing called
Integrity check so if you [__] up you
know right so you just get down on the
floor and you pump out 20. and then so
like if you're like you play the same
[__] again like I Integrity check like
the the [__] drum captain or whatever
doesn't have to go you [__] up you
[__] up before like people just go
yeah I [__] up and they just take
their [__] off and they okay but like
Integrity check are you allowed to say
400 push up this is nothing
400 is nothing it adds up in like three
yeah but look at you though like are you
allowed yeah are you but if you play
football any kid like you're just doing
20. I just wanted I just want an
internet that's all you know what I mean
yeah
I blame the kids for not knowing how to
sandbag yeah
which is you gotta [__] pretend bro
[__] you gotta be all I can't watch
all you guys
see when he's not turning just yeah hold
and it just count you count and don't
let them catch you 45 46 47 48 49 yeah
I'm doing it hit some Michelangelo
backhand spring do some hump push-ups
and [__] dude have y'all ever gone like
rap door or anything like that do you
know anybody like how bad is it it's
pretty [__] bad I know someone that
got it and it makes sense that she got
it because she's like weak no no she's
like the best but then she's also has a
crazy strong mind so she pushed herself
to that limit
so her mental power is beyond her
physical capability yeah it's like David
guys like usually it's usually a person
like David Goggins that would get it
because they're so [__] crazy yeah
their brain will literally like outwork
their muscles yeah but I I have almost
never heard of people really catching
Rabb dough that's pretty extreme like
crossfitters sometimes get it I need
this one dude that got it from being in
a CrossFit competition and he was like
he was trying to hit the mark and he's
like really competitive and then he got
it but like he was okay afterwards but
in the during it he was like it was the
worst thing ever but it's pretty serious
well you know what if I had cramps I
would have [__] cried and then went
to the hospital exactly but I would have
came back and said I'm sorry I had craps
let me [__] make this [__] work
because I know [__] all right let me
finish these 400. do you think it's the
coach's job to spot when someone might
break down in fact they're gone get him
out I would assume that uh it was it
would be a high school coach's job to
understand that it's like it's a high
school student is all no matter what you
know what I'm saying like there's I
think there's a difference between like
that's your profession versus this is
your extracurricular activity for like
high school that's true that's true but
if you want to make it to the lead also
depending on the high school Dependable
High School yeah high schools that are
on ESPN sure I I can understand that but
you know and like they know Scouts are
coming out to this thing so like that
that's the cream that okay this is Texas
right so Texas is a big football
football is a big deal like it's a big
deal this is from uh I mean Rockwall
Heath High School in Rockwall oh they're
huge I don't know yeah they have a huge
program what's the coach's record if he
has like a crazy winning record down
like his methods are probably pretty
good but at least yeah yeah yeah
yeah
like our water polo coach he was like
really hard on us but it was like it was
for good reason guys but we're also like
not that good like we were like okay
[Laughter]
we weren't known as a water polo team
you know like but I've never heard of
any water polo like anyone that goes oh
yeah my coach was easy yeah exactly one
of those hard like across the board yeah
yeah there's there's a Texas high school
football player who is defending that
coach who's under investigation because
um and in this it says that the coach
was forcing players to do up to 400
push-ups as a punishment oh up to uh
with no water breaks and stuff like that
so vocabulary just makes it sound
terminal you're easier man they did more
push-ups than [__] Coach Carter yeah
and all the suicides yeah because he had
a if you want to get back on the team he
would have to do but then the team had
to jump in and help him out and stuff
yeah so that's what they should have
done my third grade teacher my [__]
third grade teacher would give me
impossible numbers to hit like everyone
would be like no talking in class right
25 standards right they'll be like Bart
you got 200. I'm like I can't even
finish that in research I guess it's
gonna take like 10 recesses and I'm like
what [__] and then you got rhabdo do you
got my fingers do you ever make the king
just do [__] like that we don't do
punishments well you guys should yeah we
probably should one time this kid was
showing me like so I used to do when I
had to do those sentences like I will
not talk right I would do them one at a
time and then he looks over and he goes
you could do it like my way it's faster
and then I was like how he goes I will
not talk right because the scent the
teacher would usually write out the
first and he goes www and he goes down
like that and I'm all like oh my God
you're a g what I did and then my
teacher ripped it up because you know
when it says will w-i-l-l yeah I just
dropped one line to the whole paper
[Laughter]
all of the ones that were like lines if
there was its or whatever just like they
want you to suffer that's what it is if
it's a punishment they want you to go
through it you know yeah but you know
guys are failing like big time in the
school system right now it's really bad
really yeah wow there's like a like
there is a there's a gender gap going on
right now where guys are like not
graduating getting degrees is that due
to the Ethiopian Indonesian
Intercultural marriages yeah it's the
highest rate
Indonesians feeling Japan issues
Japan issues it's Madagascar guys
[Music]